bien pues tenemos aquí cuatro gráficas y
cuatro funciones y de lo que se trata
este vídeo es de juntar cada una de
estas funciones con su respectiva
gráfica y bueno antes de hacerlo te voy
a encargar que pausa este vídeo unos
segundos e intentes resolverlo por ti
mismo intenta ver cuál de cada una de
estas funciones está representado por
cuál de estas gráficas que tengo aquí
arriba y para eso te recomiendo que
utilices el valor en los extremos
muy bien pues intentamos resolver este
problema voy a trabajar para empezar con
esta primera función que tengo aquí y es
igual a 2 - un tercio elevado a la equis
así que lo primero que se me ocurre es
ver qué es lo que pasa cuando x vale
cero es decir cuánto vale y en diez de
cero y bueno tiende a cero es lo mismo
que 22 menos un tercio un tercio elevado
a la potencia cero ok pero cuánto es un
tercio elevado a la potencia cero bueno
pues nosotros sabemos que todo número
elevado al acero es 1 por lo tanto me
quedaría que ya de cero es lo mismo que
dos menos uno lo cual es exactamente lo
mismo que uno por lo tanto para empezar
podemos descartar a esta y a ésta y ésta
está si pasa por equis igual a cero y
igual aún no estaríamos en este punto de
aquí y ésta está tan bien así que tengo
dos opciones pues esta gráfica de aquí o
es esta gráfica de aquí y bueno para
saber cuál es su respectiva gráfica voy
a utilizar el valor de los extremos es
decir no voy a fijar qué es lo que pasa
cuando x ac
pero muy pero muy pero muy grande y qué
es lo que pasa cuando es que se vuelve
muy pero muy pero muy pero muy negativa
y para eso qué te parece si empezamos
pensando qué es lo que pasa con que
cuando x es muy pero muy pero muy grande
es decir imagínate que yo me tomo yo
y se me ocurre tomarme de mil quien es
de mil cuánto vale bueno pues esto es lo
mismo que dos menos un tercio un tercio
elevado a la potencia mil ahora quiero
que te des cuenta que un tercio y déjame
tomarlo con otro color esta parte de
aquí un tercio elevado a la potencia mil
esto es un número muy pero muy pero muy
cercano a cero antes de ponerlo así esto
se aproxima a cero se aproxima a cero a
cero y por qué digo esto
bueno pues imagínate tener un tercio por
un tercio por un tercio por un tercio
por un tercio mil veces
ese número es un número muy pero muy
pequeño por ejemplo un tercio elevado al
cuadrado su noveno un tercio elevado al
cubo es uno entre 27 y un tercio elevado
a la potente
es número casi cero por lo tanto 10.000
podemos decir que es aproximadamente 2
me quedaría vamos a ponerlo así llegué
de 1010 de 1.000 sería y no me cabe aquí
así que déjenme bajar un poco la
pantalla
ok vamos a bajar un poco de 1000 sería
con esta herramienta igual a 2 - y bueno
este valor se hace 0 ok se aproxima 0
entonces le voy a poner que es
aproximadamente 2 - 0 y esto es
aproximadamente ok pues 2 es decir que 7
mil 7 mil se aproxima a 2 se aproxima
aproxima
2 ok 10.000 se aproxima 2 y eso quiere
decir que entre más grandes se haga x
esta función se va a aproximar más y más
y más a 2 ahora de las funciones que
tenemos aquí arriba y dejamos subir otra
vez un poco en la pantalla de estas 4
funciones que tengo aquí cuál de ellas y
bueno de hecho solamente quedaban estas
dos cuál de ellas se aproxima dos y
seguramente lo primero que me vas a
decir es que es está aquí porque esta de
aquí cuando x hace muy pero muy grande
esta función también crece sin embargo
está cuando hay que se hace cada vez más
grande esta función se acerca y se
acerca y se acerca al valor de igualados
por lo tanto ya podríamos estar seguros
que esta función esta función es la
función y es igual a 2 - un tercio
elevado a la equis
un tercio elevado a la equis de lujo
ahora para estar completamente seguros
qué te parece si vemos qué es lo que
pasa cuando existe un valor muy pero muy
pero muy negativo así que déjenme bajar
un poco la pantalla y seguir para acá
vamos a ver ahora qué es lo que pasa
dada esta función cuando exista un valor
muy negativo es decir cuánto valdría y
por ejemplo de menos 1000 de menos 1000
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que 2
menos a un tercio un tercio elevado en
la menos 1000 elevado a la menos 1000
ahora tenemos una potencia negativa
recuerda que esto es exactamente lo
mismo que tener 2 - y la potencia
negativa la podemos convertir en
positiva tomándonos el recíproco de este
número es decir un tercio su recíproco
es 33 elevado a la 1000 ok ahora 2 - 3
elevado a la mil esto es un número muy
negativo fíjate bien si a 2 le quitó 3
elevado a una potencia gigante esto se
vuelve cada vez más
y más y más negativo lo que quiere decir
que cuando x es muy negativa que también
va a ser muy pero muy negativa y esto lo
podemos tener aquí arriba y comprobar
que si en efecto es esta gráfica de aquí
cuando toma x un valor muy negativo que
toma también un valor muy negativo y
ahora si podemos dar seguro que es esta
gráfica de aquí vamos a ver qué es lo
que pasa con esta siguiente función y
para eso vamos a hacer lo mismo primero
quiero ver cuánto vale ya de cero es
decir ver cuánto vale esta función
cuando sustituimos a x por 0 y esto lo
mismo que a bueno me quedaría un medio
un medio elevado esto a la potencia 0 -
2 y esto me queda que de 0-10 de cero es
igual a 1 un medio elevado a la cero es
uno menos todos lo cual es menos 1
ok cuál de estas funciones cuando x vale
0 10 vale menos 1 está no está tampoco
está está así cuando x vale 0 que vale
menos 1 ok y ésta está
ok entonces tenemos dos posibles
soluciones en la gráfica 1 en la gráfica
2 ahora para ver cuál es nuestra opción
correcta qué te parece si hacemos lo
mismo vamos a pensar en el
comportamiento en los extremos y para
eso qué te parece si de esta función
original este de aquí vemos qué es lo
que pasa cuando x se hace muy pero muy
pero muy positiva imagínate que yo le
pongo a x el valor de un millón cuánto
sería un medio elevado a un millón
bueno pues un medio elevado de un millón
sería un número muy pero muy pero muy
cercano a cero por la misma razón
imagínate tener un medio por un medio
por un medio por un medio así un millón
de veces por lo tanto aquí me quedaría
cero y aquí me quedaría menos 2 eso
quiere decir que cuando x se hace muy
pero muy grande esta función la función
ya que depende de x tendería a menos 2 a
menos 2 y cuál de estas dos pasa eso
bueno si te das cuenta es esta de aquí
esta gráfica de aquí cuando x hace muy
grande y tiende a menos 2 a este valor
de kim entonces parece ser que ésta
la gráfica número 2 tiene como función
esta de trabajo y es más vamos a
escribirlo james es igual a un medio un
medio elevado a la x menos 2 ahora para
estar completamente seguros qué te
parece si pensamos que es lo que va a
pasar cuando x toma un valor muy pero
muy pero muy negativo bueno imagínate
que x vale menos un millón aquí no
quedaría bien es igual a un medio
elevado a la menos un millón menos 2 y
cuánto es eso
bueno como tenemos una potencia negativa
aquí me quedaría menos un millón 1 2 3 1
2 3 como tengo una potencia negativa
para pasarla a positiva me voy a tomar
el recíproco de un medio lo cual es 2-2
elevada a la un millón menos 2 bueno
pues eso es un número muy grande
imagínate a todos elevado a la un millón
y bueno y esto le quitamos 2 me quedaría
pues un número gigante muy pero muy
grande
en efecto es esta gráfica de aquí fíjate
bien si x toma un valor muy negativo
bien se hace cada vez más grande es
justo lo que me dice aquí x muy negativa
y muy grande y bueno ahora sí podemos
estar completamente seguros gracias al
comportamiento de los extremos que en
efecto la gráfica número 2 representa a
la función a número 2 ok
pues ahora pensemos en las últimas dos
entonces para eso déjeme quitar esto de
aquí para no confundirnos y vamos a
pensar en la función número 3 y es igual
a 2 a la equis y creo que de una manera
muy parecida voy a ver qué es lo que
pasa con 7 070 es igual a 2 a la 0 y
bueno todo un número elevado de acero es
1 y eso quiere decir que cuando x vale 0
y vale 1 es decir que es o esta gráfica
de aquí o esta gráfica de aquí y bueno
podríamos hasta concluir que es esta de
aquí y es igual a 2 a la equis porque
éste ya la tenemos ocupada pero no hay
que copiar nos vamos a ver si en efecto
se cumple esto
aunque pasa cuando x es muy pero muy
pero muy grande imagínate no sé 150 2
elevado a las 150 guau este es un número
muy grandote sería 2 por 2 por 2 por 2
por 2 150 veces eso quiere decir que
cuando x se hace muy grande que también
se hace muy grande como como esta
función de aquí como esta gráfica de
aquí cuando x hace muy grande y esto me
un valor muy grande tenemos como por
aquí y si pasa lo contrario
qué pasa si x tuvo un valor muy pero muy
pero muy negativo bueno pues imagínate
tener dos elevado a la menos 150 vamos a
verlo aquí
jett de menos 150 esto me quedaría 2
elevado a la menos 150 pero otra vez
tenemos una potencia negativa entonces
esto es exactamente lo mismo que tomarme
el recíproco de 2 lo cual es un medio un
medio elevado a las 150 ok y un medio
elevado a las 150 ya como potencia
positiva esto es lo mismo que un medio
por un medio por un medio por un medio
150 veces
es un número muy cercano cero y si te
das cuenta aquí pasa exactamente eso
cuando exista un valor cada vez más
negativo que tuvo un valor muy cercano a
cero se aproxima a cero
de hecho la recta el día igual a cero es
la acin total de esta función
exponencial ok de lujo y bueno creo que
si descartamos todas nuestras opciones
podríamos decir que esta es la función
que es igual a menos 3 elevado a la
equis pero de todas maneras vamos a
verificarlo y seguramente aquí el primer
problema que se te ocurre es decir tengo
y es igual a menos 3 a la equis o menos
3 elevado a la equis donde pongo el
signo menos a dentro del paréntesis o
afuera de él y bueno si recordamos el
orden de las operaciones recuerda que
siempre se hace primero las potencias
antes de lo que se hace en la
multiplicación y la división por lo
tanto esto lo podemos escribir como
james es igual a menos y equipo de poner
paréntesis 3 elevado
y aquí ya se nota claramente que el
menos está al último de realizar esta
operación ahora imagínate que tuviéramos
3 elevado en x ésta es una función
exponencial clásica pero como tengo aquí
un signo menos todo se va a voltear es
decir cuando x es igual a cero vamos a
ponerlo 70 esto lo que daría menos 13
elevado a la cero lo cual es uno menos 1
es decir que cuando x vale 0 10 vale 1 y
estamos justo aquí de lujo vamos bien
ahora qué pasa si tomamos un valor muy
grande en x bueno pues me quedaría que
bien es igual a menos 3 elevado a una
potencia muy grande lo cual es un número
gigante y si a ese número muy grande lo
multiplicamos por menos me va a dar un
número muy negativo eso quiere decir que
cuando x se hace cada vez más grande
lleva a tomar un valor muy negativo de
lugo es justo lo que pasa aquí cuando x
crece ok ya toma un valor cada vez más
pero más pero más negativo 10 decrece
ahora qué es lo que pasa cuando tomamos
un valor negativo en x vamos a seguir
con la idea del comportamiento de los
extremos supongamos que existe un valor
muy pero muy pero muy negativo bueno
pues aquí no quedaría 3 elevado una
potencia muy negativa y de la misma
forma que aquí me va a quedar el
recíproco de 3 en una potencia positiva
es decir un tercio elevado a la potencia
positiva y un tercio cuando elevamos a
una potencia muy positiva eso se vuelve
un número cercano a cero ok y menos por
cero bueno pues eso sería todavía cero
entonces esta gráfica se va acercando a
cero pero en lugar de acercarse a cero
por arriba se va a acercar a cero por
abajo y de lujo ya tenemos que esta
gráfica representa a la función número 4
la gráfica 1 con la función número 4 la
gráfica 2 con la función número 2
la gráfica 3 para la función número 3 y
por último la gráfica 4 con la función
número uno de lujo hemos resuelto este
ejercicio hasta la próxima